slay a carpet I made a try and then last
night with a lot of gloves I was except
you can't do anything with the gloves I
realized like I couldn't I couldn't
drink water because if I had to go to
the bathroom it was a whole thing
because the gloves were a shrug so it
was all connected oh can't open your
phone nothing put that up in my phone
that was kind of nice
um I noticed we have a little Buffy
reunion on the carpet we do there's more
to come
a few other surprises tonight I mean
seeing all your co-stars tonight there's
all these surprises I mean do the
memories come flooding back
yes and then the blinding flashes kind
of change all of that too so you are
well you're an executive producer on the
show you got the power to make guest
stars happen on wolf pack any chance
we'll see any former co-stars maybe
Freddie could pop by I think it depends
on the story you know I think you don't
want to do things for the factor just to
surprise people it has to be sort of you
know innate for the show so you never
know
um this young cast I love them so much
they've all been singing your Praises
um since you know this these
Supernatural shows tend to blow up what
advice do you have for them especially
if the show does take off the way we
think it will you know it's funny I was
just saying yesterday that it's not even
so much my advice I feel like for as
much as I can teach them they have so
much to teach me and I try every day to
look through their eyes and see
everything as new and exciting and it's
it's definitely a two-way street
have you noticed by the way speaking of
just like resurgences there's been a
huge Resurgence of Scooby-Doo on talk
yes it's by dog I mean I wouldn't know
because I'm not on Tic Tac but my
daughter tells me
um can I ask you about my favorite clip
it offered so much more than every other
cartoon it was so ahead of its time it
had a story they they worked hard to
figure it out and it wasn't gender
specific it wasn't a voice cartoon or a
Girls cartoon or any of those things it
was a talking dog you know what I mean
that was there wasn't anything Clues
it's probably one of me and Freddie with
the dog yes by the way that was sort of
me and Rodrigo yesterday too I feel like
that's actually my natural Dynamic
apparently because Rodrigo would go into
like these long stories and I would just
do this I was Freddy to his Rodrigo
Sarah it's a talking dog yeah it's a
talking dog what would it take to get
the mystery gang back together do you
guys think you would ever reunite
I think they moved on to cartoons now
they're back to cart I think it's like
it's all cyclical right so it was like
cartoon live action they're back to
cartoon now
[Music]